Two coding models. One costs $25 a
million output tokens and lies behind an
API you can never open. The other is
free to download, beats it on real
benchmarks, and a trick that shipped
this month makes it run three times
faster. This is Kimi K3 from a lab
called Moonshot AI. Hand it a broken
front end and it rebuilds it. The same
league as Claude Opus and on blind
developer voting it actually beats it,
except the weights are public. You can
run this one yourself. Then came the
part nobody expected. A lab called
Inter- act bolted a trick called D-Spark
onto Kimi K3 and on a single request it
jumps from 118 tokens a second to 370.
Watch the tokens fly. And here's the
wild part. The output is byte identical.
Not similar, identical. Same weights,
same answer, same every character, just
far fewer trips through the GPU. No
retraining, no fine-tune, no quality
tax. Start with the model itself. On the
Artificial Analysis Intelligence Index,
Kimi K3 scores 57. Claude Opus 4.8
scores 56. That gap is one point. On the
front end code arena, a blind developer
vote where no one knows which model they
are rating, K3 entered at number one
with an Elo of 1,679.
Claude Fable 5 was second at 1,631.
The older Kimi K2.6 was sitting at
number 18. On Frontier's WE, it posts
81.2.
On Terminal Bench 2.1, it posts 88.3.
On SWE Marathon, it scores 42.0 and
leads the field. This is not a toy. Now
the money. Claude Opus 4.8 runs about
$25 per million output tokens. Kimi K3
runs at $15. And per completed task, the
real cost of a hard job, Artificial
Analysis puts K3 at about 94 cents
against Opus 4.8 at $1.80. Roughly half
the bill. And the weights ship on
hugging face under a modified MIT
license. The leader undercut for half
price and left the door open. So the
model is strong and it is cheaper. Deep
spark is what makes it fast. And these
two belong together in a way that
matters. Three parts. First, why Kimi K3
is a genuine Claude beater. Second, how
deep spark actually squeezes out that
three times speed up. Third, the honest
catch because there is always a catch.
Let us get into it. Kimi K3 is a mixture
of experts model, 2.8 trillion
parameters in total. But for any single
token, only 16 of its 896 experts
actually fire. That is 104 billion
active parameters per forward pass from
a pool nearly three times the size of
deep seek V4 Pro. Picture a firm with
almost a thousand specialists and every
meeting only pulls in the exact 16 who
know the answer. Full knowledge, a
fraction of the work. It holds a full
million tokens of context, an entire
code base, every file, every test, every
comment in mind at once. It pulls that
off with Kimi Delta attention, a hybrid
of linear and full attention that
Moonshot says delivers 6.3 times faster
decoding at million token context
compared to standard quadratic
attention. And it ships with native
vision, not a bolted on adapter, native.
It reads images, screenshots, and video
as part of the same model. Line the
scores up. Artificial analysis
intelligence index, 57, one point ahead
of Opus 4.8. Front end code arena, first
place ahead of fable five, GPT 5.6 saw,
and everyone else. SWE marathon, 42.0,
leading the field by seven points.
Frontier SWE, 81.2. For an open model,
this was is supposed to happen yet.
Watch it work. Point Claude code at Kimi
K3, hand it a failing test suite, and it
reads the stack trace, edits files
across the repo, and turns the whole
suite green. The same agent loop you
would run with Opus on weights you own.
Here's the same job priced two ways.
Claude Opus, $4.8, $25 a million output
tokens. Kimi K3, $15. Same task, nearly
half the bill per run, and you are
allowed to read every last weight.
Because it ships on hugging face, the
copy you pull keeps working forever. No
wait list, no per seat fee, no terms
that can be revoked overnight. If
Moonshot vanished tomorrow, your local
copy never stops running, and you do not
need a new tool. Claude code, cursor,
Klein, any agent that speaks the OpenAI
API format. Point its base URL at Kimi
K3 instead. Keep the harness you already
know. Swap the brain underneath. The
agent never notices the difference. So,
why is Kimi K3, or any large model,
slow? Because it writes one token at a
time. To produce a single word, it runs
the entire network, gets one token back,
then does it all over again for the
next. Every word is a full round trip.
Speculative decoding breaks that rule. A
small, fast draft model sprints ahead
and guesses the next several tokens.
Then the big model checks all those
guesses in one pass. The right ones are
kept for free. It is spell check for the
future. But classic speculative decoding
has a weakness. The draft is dumb, so
the big model rejects a lot of guesses,
and every rejected guess is wasted work.
Push too hard, and you actually slow
down. How big is the win with DSpark,
really? On Kimi K3 and VLM, with DSpark
enabled, throughput goes from 118 tokens
per second to 370. That is a 3.14 times
improvement on a single request,
measured on Nvidia GB300
hardware. On coding and other low
entropy tasks, the draft model gets
accepted about 4.73 tokens per step. On
creative writing and other high entropy
tasks, it drops to around 2.61.
The win scales with how predictable the
work is. Code is predictable. Deep Spark
rewards that. Deep Spark attacks the
bottleneck from three angles at once. A
block diffusion backbone drafts seven
tokens in a single parallel pass, not
one by one. A lightweight Markov head
stitches those tokens together so they
read like a real sentence, not a random
bag. And a confidence head scores how
likely each guest token is to survive,
so the engine only bothers verifying the
ones worth checking. It literally
decides what not to verify. Skip the
sure things, spend the compute where it
counts. And remember, none of this
changes the answer. The verification
step guarantees the output is exactly
what the model would have written token
by token. You are not trading quality
for speed. You are getting the speed for
free. Here's why these two belong
together. Infra Act built the Kimi K3
Deep Spark draft model to mirror K3's
own MLA attention design, which means
the draft and the target share one KV
cache layout. That is a compact 576
element latent per token. So KV
offloading and prefill decode
disaggregation work without any separate
page format. The draft was trained on
hidden states extracted from VLLM
itself, the same engine that serves it.
So the numerics it learns from are the
numerics it meets at inference. One
afternoon of compute to train the
drafter, then the speed up is yours to
keep. The on-ramp is short. The weights
land on Hugging Face. VLLM loads the
mixture of experts natively, with full
day zero support, and the Deep Spark
drafter clips on top with a single flag
in the serve command. Open model, open
server, open speed up. Not a single
piece of the stack locked behind a
login. So here's the full picture.
Download Kimiko 3, attach the DSpark
drafter from Infract. Run the world's
largest open weight model at over three
times the base speed on hardware you
control with no API bill and no rate
limit. The model already trades blows
with Opus. DSpark makes it fly. Step
back and the pattern is obvious. One
open lab shipped a model that matches
the best closed ones. A second team
shipped a speed up that triples
throughput without touching the weights.
The frontier used to be a private
garden. It is starting to look a lot
more like a public library. Now, the
honest part. That 3.14 times speed up is
the ceiling on a single clean request,
not the promise on a busy server. For
coding and structured tasks, DSpark
performs best. For open-ended creative
work, the acceptance rate drops and the
gain shrinks toward two tokens per step
instead of four. You also need the
DSpark draft checkpoint trained
specifically for Kimiko 3. Use the wrong
drafter and the acceptance rate
collapses. A bad guesser just piles on
overhead. Then there is the elephant. It
is still a 2.8 trillion parameter model.
Serving it requires serious memory. The
checkpoint in native MXFP4 format comes
in at about 1.5 terabytes. The official
VLLM recipe requires at minimum an eight
GPU Blackwell node. Free to download is
not free to run. And on factual
questions, Artificial Analysis measured
K3's hallucination rate at 51% up from
39% on its predecessor. It gets more
things right overall, but it also
confidently gets more things wrong. For
code generation and agentic tasks, that
trade-off is often fine. For anything
where a wrong confident answer is worse
than an honest abstention, verify the
output. Four numbers to keep: 2.8
trillion parameters, 104 billion active,
one point ahead of Opus 4.8 on the
intelligence index, half the cost per
task, and 3.14 times faster for byte
identical output. The takeaway is
simple. The best models are no longer
only the closed ones, and the fastest
tricks no longer live only inside the
biggest labs. Kimmy K3 proved open can
compete. Deep Spark proved open can be
quick. Together, they proved you can
have both. So, here is the real
question. If a free model can match the
best and a free trick can make it fly,
[snorts]
what exactly are you still paying for?
That is the one to sit with.